(piano music)
- [Narrator] This is Rainbow,
a red-sided eclectus parrot.
That deep green plumage,
with a tint of blue,
signifies that Rainbow is a male bird.
Female eclectuses have deep red feathers,
and until the 20th
century, males and females
were considered different species.
Native to Papua New Guinea,
these beautiful birds
nest high up in the tropical rainforests.
They are considered to be
extremely intelligent birds.
And amongst the best in
talking ability for parrots.
Their vocal skills and stunning plumage
have made them highly
desirable in the pet trade.
While logging and other
forms of habitat destruction,
have caused their population
to decline steadily.
This is the red-sided eclectus parrot.